can I be using a different computer on the internet while using the rife that kind of
goes to that other question as well.
So can I be sitting in my bed, running the rife and then open up my iPad or my laptop and
be on the internet while using the rife?
Yes, you can.
So the only caveat to that would be it, you know, it could interfere with your computer function
if the bulb was sitting right next to the computer or the iPad, that's just a possibility.
Is the iPad or the computer, the laptop that I'm using, you get to interfere with my
treatment?
That's my big question.
I don't want it to interfere with my treatment.
I'll stay off of it if it's not going to hurt my treatment.
It's not going to hurt your treatment.
So no, you could, you're fine to do that.
It will not affect the frequencies coming out of the bulb.
It won't affect your treatment negatively in any way.